Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas
has temporarily blocked The subpoena
which would force Republican senator
Lindsey Graham to have to testify in
Georgia in that 2020 election fraud
election fraud
investigation why is this notable well
it's notable because Clarence Thomas is
married to Ginny Thomas and Jenny Thomas
is an extraordinarily prominent election
denier who was in touch with all sorts
of folks involved with the January 6th
Insurrection in no sensible uh country
on no sensible planet in no logical
Universe would Clarence Thomas be able
to make decisions related to anybody and
anything connected with that election
and indeed that is what is going on CNBC
reports Supreme Court Justice Clarence
Thomas temporarily blocks Senator
Graham's subpoena from Georgia grand
jury remember Georgia is the state in
which Donald Trump said I need 11 000
votes give me a break try to coerce
Florida I'm sorry Georgia officials
um into finding the votes that he needed
in order to win that state and I know
that we are days away from the 2022
midterms but yes this was all in the
2020 presidential election the CNBC
article adding uh the Fulton County
grand jury investigating possible
criminal interference in the 2020
election in the state by former
president Trump and allies including
Graham Trump had pressured Georgia's top
election officials to find him
enough votes to overturn the win by Joe
Biden a federal appeals court last week
refused a request by Graham to delay The
subpoena how on Earth is Clarence Thomas
still allowed to rule on anything even
remotely related to the 2020 election
never mind this particular case the
husband of a major denier of the actual
results of that election
arguably Jenny Thomas what do we call
her a January sixer
I I think that is probably the most
logical uh term to use
he has the ability to block a subpoena
related to the very lies perpetrated
which deny the validity of George's
election
which his wife was doing
utterly absurd
then as far as Lindsey Graham goes have
we seen anyone short of Donald Trump
himself work this hard not to testify
now I'm gonna say something and it we
have to take it in context what happened
to if you're innocent you have nothing
to worry about now listen I understand
and I know many of you understand that
it makes sense to get a lawyer if you
can afford one
of course I I would also uh take a
lawyer's advice and if it made sense to
try not to testify or to plead the fifth
of course I would do it but it is this
very same right wing that has insisted
previously
if you're innocent you should have
nothing to hide you should have no
reason to plead the fifth you should
have no reason to try to ignore or get
out of responding to a subpoena it is
they who have made that case all along
and it is those very same people who are
taking a different approach now when it
comes to them we saw the trumps
including Donald Trump himself plead the
fifth in a number of different
depositions and in different
circumstances when it was Trump who said
the mob pleads the fifth
you don't need to do that if you're
innocent all of Hillary's people who
pled the fifth clearly are guilty
because pleading the fifth is a sign of
guilt now they're doing it uh and so of
course reasonable people understand
you get the most competent counsel you
can to represent you the most competent
Council you can find or can afford
there's no question about that but they
are the ones who have been saying listen
when people don't have anything to hide
you just show up you say what you know
and that's it now if you confront them
with that now they would say no no no
but sir that applies in normal
situations these are partisan witch
hunts meant to get around
the uh uh proper use of the justice
system to weaponize that very just and
so these are extenuating circumstances
where of course if this was a normal
situation we would just testify we would
never plead the fifth they will always
have such an excuse but understand at
the end of the day they are hypocrites
all of their principles small government
less regulation
allowing states to make decisions
just showing up and cooperating with law
enforcement all of those things are only
principles they State when it is
convenient for them it's now
inconvenient and now Clarence Thomas
helping out Lindsey Graham albeit
potentially only temporarily last night
Ron DeSantis the Republican governor of
Florida was brutalized by Challenger
Charlie Crist to the point where at one
at multiple moments during the debate
DeSantis appeared to be malfunctioning
his brain looked like it was
malfunctioning he didn't know what to
say and in some cases didn't say
anything this is Wild Charlie Crist is
almost certainly going to lose to Rhonda
Sanders now losing by about 10 points in
Florida but this was one of the best
performances by Charlie Crist of any
2022 candidate let's get right into it
now by the way before as we jump in
even many of the topics
were topics that it's sort of a joke
that they were even being discussed
critical race Theory
um talking about the fact that trans
people exist the the very existence of
these issues rather than substantive
issues of actual relevance uh it already
shows the degree to which the right has
dominated the framing and has shifted
the Overton window to the absurd but
let's put that aside for a second Ron
DeSantis doesn't like the approach that
some schools are taking because he says
it teaches that the U.S was built on
Stolen Land wait a second wasn't it it
actually if you look around the country
they do have programs unfortunately well
they will take a student look at their
race say okay you're white you're an
oppressor if you're black you're
oppressed and think about what that does
to a six or seven-year-old kid that's
wrong you're saying that you have people
that are teaching and actually his
running mate has said this in the past
that teaching the United States was
built on Stolen land that is
inappropriate for our schools it's not
true and I'm happy can you imagine now
it it's not unique like it's
we live in the U.S so a lot of history
that's taught to kids is U.S history you
know in other countries interestingly
enough
kids are taught more global history but
okay put that aside for a second it's
the U.S so kids are taught us history
it's not unique that the U.S now exists
on what we would accurately call stolen
land I mean countries in 2022 are on
land that was stolen won by War
annexed purchased or created by
International treaty it's not really a
special thing it's not unique to the
United States the Roman Empire the Zulu
Empire the Mongol Empire you look at the
history of how Japan came to be what it
is it's all a combination of these few
mechanisms it's not special
it's not a unique pejorative to teach
the reality these people live in a
fantasy world now what became a very big
issue during yesterday's debate and
Charlie Chris handled it very well
Charlie Crist pointed out multiple times
DeSantis is angling to run for president
will he commit to actually serving out
his four-year gubernatorial term and
each time DeSantis was more and more
flustered by it very very interesting
let's take a look Ron you talk about Joe
Biden a lot I understand you think
you're going to be running against him I
can see how you might get confused but
you're running for governor you're
running for governor and I have a
question for you you're running for
governor why don't you look in the eyes
of the people of State of Florida and
say to them if you're re-elected you
will serve a full four-year term as
Governor yes or no
[Applause]
yes or no this is the point at which it
looks like desantis's brain is
malfunctioning will you serve a full
four-year term if you're re-elected
governor of Florida
it's not a tough question
it's a fair question he won't tell you
we did not agree on the candidates
asking each other since Governor it's
your turn well listen I know that
Charlie is interested in talking about
2024 and Joe Biden but I just want to
make things very very clear the only
worn out old donkey I'm looking to put
out to pasture is Charlie Chris so there
of course Chris about 20 something years
older than Ron DeSantis and Ron DeSantis
going in that direction but this really
didn't get any better uh it continued
and it was it was quite ugly and telling
about Ron DeSantis only worn out old
donkey I'm looking to put out the
pasture is Charlie Chris
yeah well Ron we know you love to bully
people and the little name calling you
just exchanged I can take it but you
shouldn't do it when children are
standing behind you at a press
conference and they're wearing a mask
but apparently Chris did very very well
in this debate I don't know that it will
actually be enough to make a difference
but it was quite a scene because you
like having it as an issue for political
scoring in points that you want to have
for a future campaign and let me remind
the viewers he wouldn't even answer you
if he would stay four years if you
re-elect him as your Governor you're
running for governor you're asking them
to vote for you for governor at a
minimum you ought to be able to tell
them if you get reelected you'll serve
as governor Ron Governor so we had the
border that was in much better shape in
January of 2021 and the audience really
noticing he does not want to answer that
question because he obviously is getting
set up to run for president
then the topic of abortion came up Ron
DeSantis said he's proud of the 15-week
abortion ban that Florida passed and he
wrongly claims that at 15 weeks babies
are fully formed I'm proud of the 15
weeks that we did I know Charlie Crist
opposes that even though the baby is
fully formed has a heartbeat can feel
pain and can suck their thumb he also
supports set selective abortions that
was someone's screaming liar he's used
to discriminate against little girls he
supports dismemberment abortions where
they literally will tear the baby limb
from Limb and he supports taxpayer
funding of abortion all the way up until
the moment of birth and that is wrong
yeah now understand that there is debate
over what fully formed means certainly
there is no viability at 15 weeks but
the truth is that it's actually
irrelevant to the debate and what I mean
by that is the following do you think
for a second if it was proven to the the
extent that it could be proven that a
fetus is not fully formed by any
definition at 15 week weeks do you think
people like DeSantis would all of a
sudden go oh you know what
now that we've determined the fetus
isn't fully formed at 15 weeks I'm okay
with abortion no of course not that's
the trick that it doesn't actually
matter to them they are just coming up
with whatever they can say to justify
increasingly Draconian abortion
restrictions the crowd wasn't loving it
at another moment the topic of business
came up
Charlie Chris doing an excellent job of
flipping around who is pro-business on
DeSantis who claims to be a very
pro-business Republican Chris was very
well prepared I'm pro-business I want to
make sure we keep our businesses open
I'm not the governor who attacked Walt
Disney World because they dang to
express their point of view
I'm not the governor who attacked the
cruise industry because I just wanted to
make sure that their customers weren't
sick before they got on the boat that's
you you're the most anti-business
Governor I've ever seen
DeSantis was increasingly annoyed and
interestingly
um he he had this attitude sort of
similar actually to Marco Rubio in his
debate last week that even having to be
there is sort of beneath him he seemed
resentful that he even had to debate the
topic of the Martha's Vineyard flights
came up remember this stunt wherein uh
Marco I'm sorry not Marco Rubio Ron
DeSantis paid to fly migrants from Texas
to Martha's Vineyard
um and again Christ was very well
prepared State congressman
I thought what the governor did was a
horrible political stunt
um you know we have an immigration
problem we have a problem at the border
we need to secure the Border I agree
with all of that but it doesn't mean
that you use Florida taxpayers dollars
to Charter two jets go to Texas lie to
people to get them onto planes fly them
up to the northern part of our country
and and one of them's a one-year-old
baby
another is a pregnant woman you're
willing to use people like that in this
case they were Hispanics Venezuelan in
particular
and have them as props for your
political gain that's not the way to
change policy you can change policy and
do what's right to secure the quarter by
having comprehensive immigration reform
that's what I voted for in Congress when
you're in Congress you wouldn't do it
because you want to keep this issue
alive you want to have it as a wedge
issue and you want to pull political
stunts like you did with the taxpayers
dollars of the people of Florida that's
not what it's for that's not what you
should have done it isn't funny it's not
right and you we're inhumane and how you
treated these people and DeSantis really
didn't have any substantive rebuttal it
was just sort of like well you know we
have a real problem and the Chris Biden
border crisis and blah blah blah blah
blah last thing here when Ron DeSantis
tried to close out the debate claiming
he led the pandemic response based on
facts someone very succinctly in the
audience just yells outlier which is of
course an accurate criticism when a once
in a century pandemic hit I led based on
facts not based on
right so a disastrous debate for Rhonda
santis but I hate to tell you it
probably will not make a difference if
you live in Florida you should vote
there's no doubt about it it is right
now a 10 point deficit a 10 point
deficit for Charlie Christ Charlie Crist
would be a fine governor for Florida
Ronda santis is a disaster he is using
this to set up his presidential run if
it's convenient if it ends up going that
way without a doubt really good debate
for Charlie Crist DeSantis fumbling and
looking malfunctioning almost trump-like
glitches but DeSantis sadly will
probably win but maybe not let's all
vote remember that we have a YouTube
channel approaching 2 million
subscribers I found out an incredible
piece of data last week my colleague
John told me this even though
we had four and a half million different
people watch videos on our YouTube
channel last month
only about one and a half million are
subscribed there are three million
viewers on YouTube who watch our Clips
but aren't subscribed make sure you hit
that subscribe button because it is so
important for the algorithm and for
signaling to YouTube that our content is
engaging enough for people to want to
subscribe there are three million of you
out there and I am speaking to you today
make sure to join the ranks of our
YouTube subscribers it's free we will
take a quick break and be back right
after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
so yesterday I told you that Texas
Republican senator Ted Cruz was in New
York City for the Astros Yankees game
and he was brutally booed and heckled at
Yankee Stadium more substantively
yesterday he appeared on the New York
city-based talk show The View and it was
completely off the rails one of the most
bad faith interview performances I've
seen in a very long time and I want to
go over some of this with you because it
is so emblematic of how these folks
operate in a fact-free and also
completely a moral framework The View
co-host Anna Navarro a lifelong
Republican but an anti-trump Republican
she confronts Cruz and says how did you
go from being against Trump and him
calling your wife ugly to suddenly you
support the guy take a look at this
frankly don't know how you'll get over
your wife being called ugly I don't know
how you get over those kind of
calamities against your father but you
obviously have gotten over it today
you're saying a very different tune so
tell us were you lying then or are you
lying now yeah that's that's a loaded
question there I think a lot of people
have the same question it's a very
different Ted Cruz that we're seeing
we are and we do not agree that that's
very different Ted Cruz than today what
I would say is this in 2016 we had a
primary where Donald Trump and I beat
the living crap out of each other I'll
tell you Heidi laughed when he said that
my father laughed by the way my dad
didn't just kill Kennedy he's got Jimmy
Ted it was so funny when Donald Trump
called me ugly
I'm calm I'm buried in the backyard
if they went after each other and at the
end of the day he won and I had a
decision to make in November of 2016.
yes am I going to stand on principles
and maybe be on the outs with the
president or do I want to start sucking
up to keep access to power he'd been
elected president I got a responsibility
to represent 30 million Texans I I could
have decided my feelings are hurt I'm
going to take the ball and go home and
not do my job but if I was prepared to
do that I better be prepared to resign
from my job because I have a
responsibility so what I did is I is I
went and said listen we have an
opportunity to make a difference for
this country and I want to roll up my
sleeves and lead the fight to actually
deliver on promises we were talking a
minute ago about the incredible booming
economy we saw seven million people get
off of food stamps seven million people
and food stamps does not actually
address how and why Ted Cruz got in line
with Trump and remember that if
everybody laughed about Trump calling
Heidi Cruz ugly back in 2016 why was it
that in the immediate aftermath Ted Cruz
referred to Trump as a sniveling coward
because of those comments and said leave
Heidi the hell alone if everybody
laughed and had a good time after that
why did he do it Anna Navarro also
confronts Ted Cruz with some of the
specific things he said about Trump what
you said about him back in 2016 during
the campaign let's take a look I'm
trying to tell you what I really think
about
this man is a pathological liar true
doesn't know the difference between
truth and lies he lies
practically every word that comes out of
his mouth the man is utterly amoral if
morality does not exist for him true
yeah so I have to ask you because you
know I'm married to a Cuban man I
frankly don't know how you'll get over
your wife being called ugly I don't know
how you get over those kind of
calamities okay so then they go into the
part that we already saw another
interesting moment during this was that
Ted Cruz just could not be in New York
City and not get heckled climate
activists interrupted the interview and
then Whoopi Goldberg says let us do our
job and it just gets completely crazy
it's very simple if you look at
inflation the Nobel Laureate Economist
Knowlton Friedman explained in the
United States inflation has one cause
and one cause only
foreign
inflation in the United States has one
cause and one cause of it and that is
when the federal government spends too
much money okay we have seen trillions
and trillions of dollars spent by Joe
Biden the Democrats just last year last
year the federal government took in four
trillion dollars in taxes
in history we've ever taken in the
problem is we spent nearly seven
trillion dollars and that's what we do
cover climates
ladies ladies excuse us let us do our
job let us do our job we hear what you
have to say but you gotta go
you gotta go you gotta let us do our job
all right so then there they start to
get kicked out but somehow then they get
more energy and then they're back and
then they end up having to mute
everything and cut to commercial the
biggest reason people at home are saying
okay is my life better today than it was
two years ago and I think for the vast
majority of Americans the answer is no
oh my God
all right so total chaos on The View uh
ABC spokesperson put out a statement
saying that three people in the audience
interrupted The View and they were
escorted out these interviews are not
going particularly well for Ted Cruz but
I have to tell you what if you see this
Through The Eyes of right Wingers and
we're going to see things through the
eyes of right Wingers in a moment you
see a guy whose speech they are trying
to suppress
and that it is unhinged people doing it
so you know you and I know that this guy
is the lowest of the low truly but
understand that the right Wingers see
this and they go look at those liberals
they don't want to let them speak in
suppressing speech and next we are going
to look exactly at
what is going on in the minds of some of
these people
MSNBC interviewed Pittsburgh area Trump
voters in the lead up to the imminent
election about January 6th and I'm going
to play some of this for you and what
you are going to see demonstrated in
this clip
is how effective Republican
disinformation has been the stuff that
they repeat January 6th was antifa the
woman who was shot Ashley Babbitt was a
hero all of these things that you and I
go there's no evidence for this who
could possibly believe this crap here
are the people who believe this crap and
the most important message I have for
you about it is
the MSNBC didn't go and have to look in
little crevices to find folks with these
beliefs this is a disturbingly
representative sample of I would
estimate somewhere between one-fifth and
one-third of the voting public this is
scary dystopian stuff look at this and
look at how weaponized their beliefs are
Doug mastriano was at the Insurrection
and he was photographed breaching one of
the restricted areas
is that okay which area because I saw a
video where Capital officers was taking
away barriers and unlocking doors so
that's the talking point there was no
trespassing the officers let everybody
in
I mean I they opened the gate so it
shouldn't be disqualifying for an
elected official
participated in January 6. he didn't
strike anybody he didn't hurt anybody
and the only one that died was a
protester there not a capital person
unarmed female veteran that's the only
one that died the only one who died a
police officer remember unarmed female
veteran died this is the whole thing
where she she was a hero she was there
protesting peacefully in Bubba it did
die no but that was a stroke that's not
that's not on site by that that's
because he shouldn't have been a police
officer so what do you make though
support the police right the guy who
died of a heart attack he just never had
any business being in law enforcement we
backed the blue overall of January 6 I
mean it was watching that footage it was
pretty disturbing I mean there were
people throwing excrement at the walls
and it was our you know it's the capital
almost a lot like antifa's action except
on a much smaller scale will look the
same as the black lives matter right
that's what I saw the similarities
one earns Kenosha but so it's okay just
because just because one side that you
disagree with I'm saying infiltrated
antifa infiltrated Now understand if
you're listening this is a group of all
white people
it's relevant only in so far as when we
think about
what is the group most susceptible in a
sense to this type of misinformation it
does seem overwhelmingly to be uh right
wing
White
mostly male but lately increasingly
female voters and that is exactly what
we have here for the other anybody I
don't see arms anybody anybody who
caused property destruction that needs
to be dealt with yeah if you're there
making your voice heard at the people's
house no less yeah that's again it's a
fundamental constitutional right of an
American citizen and people should not
be being held political prisoner so this
is the talking point of the rioters are
being held as political prisoners which
Marjorie Taylor green uses I mean you
could spoon feed anything to these folks
and they would buy it uh because of it
for misdemeanors that's East Germany
that's Easter tactics yeah that's what's
scary
it was an actual fiery but mostly
peaceful protest
and the other ones that were the office
was the protest
legitimate in your eyes I feel like is
using it as their rice dog fire oh my
God that's exactly what they're using it
as
oh my God this is really really scary
stuff really scary stuff let's let's
skip ahead and listen to a little bit
more after
people were still there and stuff yeah
but it's but it started while he was
still speaking and and they talk about
the fact that oh he didn't do anything
for this amount of time it's like well
he was giving his speech and right so
this is the argument that Trump couldn't
have stopped what was happening because
he was still speaking when it was
happening that's not true we all were
there live the breach happened well well
after Trump was long gone the the timing
just is a lie
now again that's also a lie Trump has
insisted I requested ten thousand troops
in Nancy Pelosi denied it there is no
evidence that Nancy Pelosi denied
anything but more importantly there's no
evidence Trump requested any such troops
there is simply no evidence Trump says
it
no evidence of it they believe it's not
just some of the lies they believe every
lie yeah well it actually isn't in
Pelosi's power too
she's bigger the house she's no
authority over that whatsoever and
frankly I think that's a good thing but
well then but even so isn't she in
charge of security if there was a cap
rate of a risk that she was offered them
then why didn't she uh do anything
preemptively beef up Capital police
right but she does have this the
authority to do these are very serious
brain worms and I know well with the
pejorative there is something really
wrong here there is something very wrong
where every lie they believe and the
most important question for us is
it's very clear that just putting up
good candidates who tell the truth
and who actually care about constituents
it is not enough
so what has to happen what has to happen
I don't know the answer
and that's maybe the scariest part of
all of it we'll have these clips on our
Instagram find us on Instagram at
davidpackman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show well you
know every once in a while it does
happen that a guest cancels on us at the
last second and we had two choices today
Choice number one would have been cancel
the show throw the show in the toilet
flush it 10 to 15 times no show the
other option is let's open the phone
lines very briefly and hear from just a
few people in our audience and you know
I like people in the audience more or
less as much as I like our guests so it
seems like a very good alternative let's
do this via Discord which you can find
at davidpackman.com
Discord and I don't even want to wait
anymore let's just go right in and start
with Mike from Southeastern Pennsylvania
Mike we've got the Oz fetterman debate
tonight I know you'll be watching
oh yes I will yeah what are you
expecting
I think they're gonna probably pick on
Letterman for his health conditions yeah
I think so uh but that's my question to
you what was on your mind Mike
uh I was wondering why don't they pass a
stamp tax to raise revenue that's not
tax deductible
like for like corporate Jets or Yachts
or something
did you say a stamp tax yeah pass the
stamp tax for various luxury or excise
items yeah so stamp taxes are basically
uh sometimes they're called duties
that's d-u-t-y
they are taxes on specific types of
property purchases I mean don't there
already are a bunch right like isn't
there like a yacht tax and a pro or is
that state I guess I don't know enough
about it to know what's currently in
place
oh yeah I just noticed the inflation is
really high for um
luxury items so to clamp that down why
not just pass more Duty taxes well but I
don't know that the big concern is that
luxury goods that a tiny portion of
people can afford are expensive I think
my instinct was more as a way to
increase government revenue
it would be something to look at right
or why would you be looking to do it
yeah to increase residence with State
the post office it would create like a
sub stamp collection Market that people
would probably collect the stamps
oh boy I think we have some confusion
generally speaking when people talk
about a stamp tax it's not about
collectible stamps it's a tax on a
particular type of item
oh I know but I say just create create
stamps or create um non-fungible tokens
something that people can trade with oh
you're literally saying make stamps that
people can collect oh yeah definitely oh
my goodness Mike I don't know if you're
serious but I appreciate the call
thank you all right very good was that
was that a joke I can't even tell let's
go to Gabriel from Albany New York
Gabriel welcome
hey David how's it going it's going well
good
um I just had a question because in I
live in Upstate New York yep and as you
know this is a pretty rural Republican
area oh yeah um at least in the more
rural aspects but there's a lot of
people in my surrounding circles that
I've considered like kind and especially
intelligent people as long as I've known
them
um who have really Fallen prey to a lot
of the current rhetoric surrounding the
Republican party yes what do you think
really changed in the past probably 10
years because they often spout as an
example of why they don't trust the
government as like oh I'm you know as
you grow older you you just see that you
don't trust the government more
why do you think there's been such a
massive distrusting government
that makes people just like from
skeptical to like completely
conspiratorial there has been an overt
campaign from the right to say you can't
trust the government you shouldn't trust
the government the government can't be
trusted and of course as most reasonable
people know there are certain things
that it makes total sense to have
governments involved in and there are
other areas where it's perfectly fine to
let basically markets allocate direct
the allocation of resources but
it's been the following combination if
we zoom out is what I would say
declining education
partisan media
filter Bubbles and Echo chambers that
are self-reinforcing on social media
and a complete abandonment of policy by
the American right wing
and a replacement with exactly the types
of bullet points and talking points that
you're talking about in some total
that's a lot working against us
foreign
that makes sense yeah all right Gabriel
from Albany thank you very much for the
call we're just hearing from a few
people we had a guest cancellation and
it lets us get on the phone and hear
from a variety of uh of great people
let's go to Eric from Long Island Eric
welcome to the show what's on your mind
today oh hi David how's it going it's
going well
yeah so um uh thanks for doing this last
minute I suppose uh I didn't have too
much to say today but I'm sure you saw
the news about uh uh how Clarence Thomas
is starting to cover for uh Lindsey
Graham and Georgia did you have any
thing you wanted to say about that or is
that going to be covered it's the top
story on today's show which of course
you wouldn't know because you are on
today's show right now and it becomes
sort of this uh endless feedback loop uh
no listen
Clarence Thomas's wife
is an election denier
a January 6th adjacent individual in
touch with all sorts of players in the
Insurrection and the riots and like I
said at the top of the show I won't
repeat myself fully but he should have
nothing to do with any legal decisions
even remotely connected to the November
of 2020 election it's insane that he
does absolutely yeah and it's it's
actually quite frightening how they're
they're they're actually doing all this
in broad daylight and and it doesn't it
seems like there's not much we can do
about it it feels like there's very
little we can do about it that's for
sure
yeah yeah all right all right my friend
okay but thank you very much appreciate
that uh let's go next to Aiden from
Alberta Aiden welcome to the program
Aiden from Alberta
Aiden I'm guessing you have the wrong
audio device selected hello hello oh I
think I got it you got okay I'll make it
quick since I wasted a little time there
please so Charlie Christ very good last
night in my opinion oh yeah um and one
of the things I noticed is uh he used
some common Republican talking points
against DeSantis yeah specifically the
the uh gas prices I noticed he attacked
DeSantis on the gas prices thing yeah
which uh I was wondering if you think
democrats should do that more using
those more kind of political arguments
that the Republicans use against
themselves listen I am not going to tell
anybody
to stop using whatever works
against terrible people like Ron
DeSantis so if Charlie Crist sang listen
you want to talk about the Biden gas
prices
it's the DeSantis gas prices they're off
the charts here in Florida
if that works use it you know there's
nothing immoral about that you're not
shooting anyone you're not defrauding
anyone you're just really
strategically choosing who to blame for
something that's really a national
phenomenon in my heart of hearts I don't
think Biden nor DeSantis have much to do
with gas prices as I've said before but
it's the type of thing where I would say
if it works absolutely do it
yeah no I completely agree and uh yeah
thank you have a have a good rest of
your show today all right Aiden from
Alberta great to hear from you let's go
next to Jasper from Brazil Jasper
welcome
hi David how's it going it's going well
so I wanted to ask you
um I see countries like Argentina and
Brazil where I'm currently living trying
these same sorts of protectionist uh
trade strategies over and over again
particularly when led by populists
leftist leaders
and they often don't work to grow the
local economy of the opposite effect to
sink the local currency do you think the
left has some sort of populist trade
policy problem
um so when it comes to populism
I don't see populism really as being
policy I see populism as being a
rhetoric and a messaging strategy so
I would not say that there's a left
populism trade policy problem because I
don't think populism by definition is
policy now as applied to Argentina
specifically
it's been one disastrous decision after
another after another by every
Administration it's been Christina
Alberto macri it's it's been just
disastrous all the way down
and
it is also true that the current debt
situation which is absolutely related to
the IMF and World Bank history with
Argentina
and we can't say that there is no
responsibility or blame there is also
completely untenable that I don't know
that you're even going to trade your way
out of the problem anyway so anybody who
like the thing that will happen is
depending on which Hammer you have or
maybe better said depending on whether
you have a hammer or a drill you see
everything as either a nail or a screw
in terms of saying the problem has been
Christina and Alberto and others say no
no no no no the problem has been Makati
no no no the problem has been the IMF it
is Decades of bad decisions upon Bad
Decisions by bad leaders
and there's no one thing to blame but no
I don't think it's a populism policy
problem since populism isn't really a
policy it's a rhetoric
okay thanks may I also ask you another
question about uh bolsonaro the election
is coming up on I believe Saturday yeah
Sunday isn't it or is it Saturday no
it's a Sunday
okay Sunday uh
yeah and he seems pretty dangerous and
it it looks like he has a very good
chance to win
what do you think could happen in the
next sort of four years here in Brazil
I would defer to the real experts on
Brazilian politics I agree with you he
clearly has a shot to win but uh I I
would ask someone who is following the
Brazilian situation more closely it it
doesn't make sense for me to be the
person opining on that
okay fair thank you all right my
pleasure there is Jasper from Brazil
with a very very interesting question
let's go next to Brian from Ireland
Brian welcome
hey David sir how you doing uh sir
welcome to the program
yeah first time caller thanks a lot
um I just want to say thanks very much
for for covering these debates um on the
live streams it's really interesting for
you know someone
um looking from abroad at the American
system it's pretty interesting thank you
and my question kind of relates to that
as well
um let's say if somebody in one of these
TV networks put you in charge of
arranging the debate what kind of
changes would you make to the format
because I and I think you're in
agreement with me here that it's
intensely frustrating you know there's
never enough time to yeah develop
candidates positions never enough time
to scrutinize
when Charlie Chris tried to ask DeSantis
some basic questions you know about
really served four years yeah just
plainly ignored him and that was allowed
by the moderators no pushback whatsoever
so how would you um arrange this kind of
thing so for first and foremost there
have to be exchanges between the
candidates and in last night's debate
between DeSantis and Christ Chris kept
trying to get DeSantis to say I will or
I won't commit to serving all four years
and DeSantis just looked like his brain
was malfunctioning and then the
moderator would jump in and say we have
agreed that the candidates will not ask
each other questions or address each
other they will only talk to the
moderator now the candidates seemed to
have insisted on that sometimes it's the
moderators and the organiz organizers
who put that in I think the way we're
really going to learn more is we need
longer periods of less structured back
and forth between the candidates bring
up the issue of abortion for example
frame it with a question but then it
doesn't have to be a half hour but at
least allow five minutes of open back
and forth with the moderator being there
to be able to jump in and say well hold
on a second don't talk over each other
Christ just asked DeSantis this specific
question DeSantis can you answer that
and and sort of managing the
unstructured time to make sure everybody
gets their points across we would learn
so much more from that than from 60
seconds now you respond to me for 30
seconds but don't talk to each other
it's just it's too short it's not the
way we really make progress by talking
through a moderator talk to each other
but in a way where we can actually hear
what everybody's saying
yeah completely agree that's the
fundamental change I would make more
time on each topic and talk to each
other
I I don't see how anyone halfway
sensible could disagree with you on that
you know I'm just one that it seemed not
to want to you know I think they see it
as very risky
the the last thing for me as well I also
wouldn't have a live audience there
because it sends into a purse as well
but it was totally farcical yep
absolutely Brian from Ireland appreciate
the call
thanks David all right appreciate
getting to speak to some of you today
we'll go to a quick break and be back
with more show right after this
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
investigative journalist Bob Woodward
has announced he will be releasing uh I
believe it's close to 20 audio
recordings of his conversations with the
failed former president Donald Trump
some of these have started to trickle
out and they are disturbing now at this
point our threshold for saying something
Trump said or did is disturbing has
gotten quite High I mean looking at all
of the lists of things that he did it
really has to be something extreme to
get us to say wow that's crazy and that
is indeed what we have here let's start
with the first clip in which Donald
Trump tells Bob Woodward I have a plan
for dealing with the pandemic this was
from uh I believe July of 2020 but I
need to deploy it at a time that it will
help my re-election
not at the time where it would save the
most lives not at the time that it would
keep the most people healthy at the time
that it would be best for Trump's
re-election listen to this man more than
70 000 Americans had already died from
the virus now two months after that in
July Trump gave Woodward a ring and he
said he finally had a plan to deal with
the pandemic but Trump wanted to wait to
release it until a time when it would
better help him win re-election
[Music]
I've got 106 days that's a long time
you know if I put out a plan now people
won't even remember it in 100 I run the
last election no no but it's not just
put out the plan it's executed I am
executed you'll see it starting
overtly
overtly saying if I do it now people
will have forgotten about it when it's
time to vote
not if I do it now I might save more
people now that's not a concern
disgusting guy completely amoral in
every way immoral in fact I would argue
um Trump Compares his meeting with Kim
Jong-un the North Korean dictator in
another clip
to the sort of instant feeling of
chemistry
when Trump meets a woman and just knows
whether it's all going to happen if you
know what I mean
listen to this you meet somebody and you
have a good chemistry and there is a lot
of strength to it
you made a woman
in one second you know whether or not
it's all going to happen okay we had a
very good chemistry together you meet
just strange I mean it's not it it's not
about oh it has romantic overtones
necessarily
although there is some
enamored feeling that we get from Trump
about these dictator types he seems
enamored with the way that President XI
of China deals with drug dealers he
thinks it's great he seems enamored in a
way with Putin's attitude and he
certainly seemed enamored with Kim
Jong-un now interestingly another
incredible moment from these uh
recordings is when Trump reveals
classified information to Bob Woodward
about weapon systems and the number of
weapons Russia has and he he is just
diarrhea of the mouth classified
information now I know oh the president
can declassify whatever he wants sure do
you think Trump is carefully considering
the impact and prudency of revealing
this information to what Rob Woodward no
he's trying to brag
we have stuff that you haven't even seen
or heard about we have stuff that Putin
and she had never heard about before
getting along with Russia is a good
thing that's a bad thing all right
especially because they have 1
332 nuclear Warheads
Trump just bragging to Bob Woodward
about all of the things that he knows
and then maybe incredibly Trump gives
Bob Woodward letters from Kim Jong-un
nobody else has them but I want you to
treat them with respect I haven't
understand I understand and don't say I
gave them please okay okay but I think
it's okay normally I wouldn't have give
I wasn't going to give him to Bob you
know will you make a photo stat of them
or something no I dictated them into a
tape recorder really isn't that the best
what you make a photo stat of the
letters or something
um interestingly
Woodward is sort of handling the
documents with more care than Trump and
and what I mean by that is Woodward
isn't creating
physical copies that could then be lost
Bob Woodward seems to have more
consideration
for the sensitive nature of these
documents than even Trump himself these
are just four little Clips four little
previews of what may be to come from
these audio tapes I told you folks years
ago it will take years to learn the full
insanity of what took place during that
four-year period and indeed that is that
is the case it is taking years for all
of this stuff to come out and it is
disturbing as it is extraordinary hey I
have uh what I would call a giga cringe
moment to play for you this isn't like a
big thing but it's just a complete and
total backfire California gubernatorial
Republican nominee Brian Dahl tried to
make a Biden dementia joke during his
debate over the weekend with California
Democratic governor Gavin Newsom now
it's not like Gavin Newsom needs any
help as I've said before Newsome is
excellent in talking about the insanity
of the American right but also into
direct conversations with right Wingers
I dare you I double dare you to watch
this clip without cringing look at what
happens when Brian Dahl tries to do a
Biden dementia joke and it just Falls
humiliatingly flat did Joe Biden
legitimately win the 2022 election
against Donald Trump yeah actually he
did win the election but the big
question is he does he know that that's
that's what I wonder sometimes but I
want to talk about about he being who
Joe Biden
what do you mean by that well I I yes I
agree that he won the election but I
wonder sometimes if he actually realizes
that he's president of the United States
of course do you recognize these and
that's right you're insulting the
president United States of course he
understands he's pregnant
God what a loser
um silence
silence one of the most awkward silences
of the entire debate season there
I've seen that five times now and I
still get uncomfortable from how awkward
and how flat it falls it is not looking
good in case you were wondering for
Brian Dahl in California uh the latest
polling right now has it at
um Newsome plus 23 23 and that is
expected to be an absolutely incredible
drubbing Marjorie Taylor green yes the
radical and repugnant Republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green is
reportedly being considered to be Donald
Trump's running mate in 2024 for months
reports Business Insider Trump has
repeatedly discussed choosing Marjorie
Taylor green as his 2024 running mate
um this is per Robert Draper of the New
York Times magazine As Told to uh The
Daily Beast Trump is considering green
this won't come as a surprise to you
because of her unflagging loyalty to him
speaking on this week's episode of The
Daily beasts the new abnormal podcast
Draper claimed the discussions have been
ongoing for months it's been discussed
repeatedly now to be fair I mean how
many of these conversations has Trump
had with other people
what is Trump concerned about most of
all in a VP after the Mike Pence
experience loyalty loyalty Trump needs
someone who will quote fight for him to
overturn a presidential election
he has every reason to expect that green
would be by his side and would be his
proximate Warrior earlier this week
green told Draper she's discussed with
Trump the possibility of serving as his
running mate she said she would be
honored to serve but the GOP
establishment would not want it so
listen
she's completely out of her mind crazy
she is
um
loyal is not even the right word but yes
she's unendingly loyal to Trump in the
sense of following whatever disastrous
instinct or talking point Trump is
distracted by that week as the latest
shiny object I don't know on the one
hand why Trump thinks it would help him
to have Marjorie Taylor green and as his
running mate but in all seriousness
let's not write it off and what I mean
by that is remember that Trump won the
Republican primary of 2016.
Trump then won the presidential election
you could come to me with tears in your
eyes and say Sir Trump is considering
Jeffrey Dahmer where he's still alive as
VP and I'd say that's insane
and he still might win
the most depressing era in a long time
for sure and I don't think green
necessarily hurts Trump now on the other
hand I don't know that she necessarily
helps and what I mean by that is like in
all seriousness
does Marjorie Taylor green bring any new
voters to Donald Trump
I don't know that she does if you are in
the Romney wing of the Republican party
or the Liz Cheney wing of the Republican
party and you don't like Democrats but
you're just not sold on Trump
if Trump picks Romney maybe you go with
the Trump Romney ticket now that's not
being considered I'm just saying maybe
that gets you to go over to the Trump
side
but if you're already in kind of like
the Romney kinzinger Liz Cheney wing of
the Republican Party does Trump picking
Marjorie Taylor green get you over to
trump it doesn't seem like it and so on
the one hand I don't think because of
how delusional and dangerous and
dystopian this Republican party and
electorate is I don't know that there's
anyone that would really hurt Trump
the thing about Marjorie Taylor green is
I don't think she helps Trump find new
voters which is what he needs to do if
he hopes to defeat Joe Biden or whoever
it is on the Democratic side in November
of 24.
because he needs to find some new voters
relative to 2020. I don't know that
Marjorie Taylor green helps him do that
but I want to hear from you let me know
our voicemail number is 2192 David P
here is a great voicemail from someone
who appreciates all of the debate
coverage that we have been doing this
election season
thank you I just wanted to call to thank
you for your coverage of all of these
debates I've really been enjoying your
coverage I missed the the Santa's Chris
debate last night so I went to the gym
and started your live stream to listen
to it this morning and I was
delighted to be surprised by your new
David pochman and Mike pillow remix so
there I was
lifting weights to the sound of that
song well that is that is an absolutely
heartwarming thing to hear two things on
this one
we have streamed probably a dozen
different debates so far this election
season one of the most interesting ones
is tonight Mehmet Oz versus John
fetterman I hope you will join me at 7
30 p.m Eastern on YouTube twitch and
Facebook and secondly yes Chris Barrios
putting together one of the best remixes
ever of anything we have done listen to
just a little bit of this masterpiece
worry about my espresso machine
it's not a joke it's just I'm worried
about my Lane
and I'm married
[Music]
okay you get the point anyway remixes
debates all of it join me tonight at 7
30 p.m Eastern Oz versus fetterman we've
got a great bonus show for you today we
will talk about the new British prime
minister Rishi sunak we will talk about
Mark Hamill by the way a fan of the
David Pacman show
fan of the David Pakistan Mark Hamill
sending 500 drones to Ukraine and we
will talk about Adidas or as some call
it Adidas cutting ties with Kanye West
after the anti-Semitism explosion all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show sign up at joinpackman.com